applications of differentiation so far
we've just been differentiating stuff
and then say
done okay but now we're going to take
those derivatives and
use them we're going to apply them to
problems so what we're going to do is
with this table i want to sort of
break down what it is
wow that's a really not straight line
what the derivative tells you
once you find out what it's equal to so
we're going to look at the derivative
and then it's implication for the graph
i'm trying to connect this to
our previous topic graphing techniques
right
okay so what we're going to start with
is thinking about the derivative and
particularly it's it's value at a
particular place
so see these derivatives that you've
just worked out and what these tell you
is if you give me an x
say x equals one for each of these
different derivatives right
if you pop that in you'll get some
number at the end
right in the same way that with a
definite integral you just got a number
at the end
rather than a function okay so if you
go into some derivative you pop in a
number you substitute it
and you get some result that's positive
okay
if you substitute a value like say if i
put x equals 1
into here what do we actually get you
get 15 times one
take away four so what would your
derivative be equal to at that point
we can do arithmetic right 15 times one
take away four
you're going to get a value of 15 times
one uh
11. thank you sarang manages to get
there first so
that's a positive value right and what
that tells you about the graph
is that its gradient is going up right
it's positive so we would say the word
we use for that is it's increasing
okay now just so you have a visual cue
for this what does this look like well
your function is going up right
a straight line going up would have a
positive
derivative if you had say part of a
parabola
going like that right just the the right
hand part right that's also
going up it's increasing you could have
something like say you know this guy
here right a log function
it would look slightly different it
would look like that but it's still
going up as you go from left to right
it's still increasing okay and we get
that we can interpret that
from a positive derivative okay
let's keep on going down let's see what
happens if it's not positive what if it
was
equal to zero as we get lower and lower
and lower
what does that tell us we actually have
a special word for this right
we use the word stationary what does
that mean stationary by the way it's
stationary
with an a stationary with an e is the
stuff i'm holding in my hands
okay um how would you describe that in
words yeah
is it like i'm not sure if it's just
because
like it's the point where there's like a
horizontal line where like x
yeah okay so so
we're getting a horizontal line i'd
probably say horizontal is the key word
you said a few things there sophie right
um when you've got no it's fine um it's
all sort of fiend together when you've
got part of the curve that's horizontal
right that that's what we mean by
stationary it's not going up
it's not going down you guys sorry
good um this is by the way not the only
thing that it can look like when it's
stationary it could look for example i
was talking about parabola before
it could look like the very bottom part
of the parabola
or if it was an upside down parabola it
could look like the very
top part right and in fact there's a few
more ways that that can look there's a
few more versions of that which we're
going to explore a little bit
next period but that's the idea that
it's stationary
at that one moment it's horizontal
okay would anyone like to take a guess
what the next row if they're decreasing
ah very good well in fact
you're sort of already over here right
so increasing
what what quality what quality do i want
the derivative to have
if i'm going to decide that the graph is
decreasing what can you tell me about
the derivative
it's going to be negative right or it's
less than zero that's just two different
ways of saying the same thing
right so what does that look like
from left to right it's gone down right
so
something like this could be a straight
line could be the other part
of the parabola we were talking about uh
or could be something like
like this these are all decreasing in
the section that i've drawn them
okay so increasing stationary decreasing
they come
from the sine s-i-g-n
the sine of the derivative okay is it
positive
is it zero is it negative okay um
there's actually one last thing that the
derivative
can do
okay hold on a second so this equals
zero
um these two don't equal zero like
positive doesn't equal zero
negative doesn't equal zero i'm going to
give you a clue have a look over
at um have a look at this derivative
over here
or even let's choose a different color
this guy here and this guy here
there are some places where the
derivative isn't positive
uh it's not zero and it isn't negative
either what else could the derivative be
if it's not
any of these three
now if i put in if i put in an x value
it's it's going to be one it can't be
positive and negative at the same time
right hmm
oh you mean greater than or equal to
yeah so i guess what that would be
is if you sort of took two of these
categories and sort of like jam them
together
so i'm going to say that that is a sort
of different thing but it's just the
combination of two categories we already
have
let me try and tease it out a little
more just have a look at this very last
one this derivative here okay
what's happening when x is equal to
negative 1 over
6. what's happening to look at it
closely
like evaluate if you need to what's
going on
with that function
have a look at the derivative look at
the derivative
so so what's it let's actually do it by
the way i should have picked this up
before by the way this is
our derivative down dx
hmm okay so when we do this right
when you try and evaluate x equals
negative one over six here right what
happens to the derivative well you get d
y and dx
equals two the numerator is just one
it's independent of x there's no x's in
there so i substitute nothing happens
but on the denominator here six times
negative one over six six that's just
that's just negative one right do you
agree with that and then when you plus
one what's happened to our denominator
is zero now
think back to when we're doing graphing
techniques
what does this mean like i'm trying to
i'm trying to divide by zero right
um this function here unlike
these guys up here and if you want if
you've got desmos nearby right if your
laptop's already open you're welcome to
put this in right
this function here has as we said an
asymptote
right we usually have an asymptote at x
equals zero
but because of all this this business
here right we've had dilation happen
we've also had translation happen we've
actually moved the asymptote
we've moved it here okay so
what this means is the function doesn't
exist right the derivative
doesn't exist so what we can say over
here is
the derivative could be positive it
could be zero
it could be negative or the derivative
doesn't exist
okay okay you should it should have
backed yourself man okay now
what does this mean well um what does it
mean for this guy
for this particular example right what
it means is there's what we call a
discontinuity
dis continuity there's a point at which
the graph
does not exist okay
yeah so if there's like some break in
the graph right so um the hyperbola is
another
example see this guy here right in fact
i may even write it underneath
for example y equals 1 over x right
if we differentiate that that's x to the
negative one
you'll get negative one over x squared
that'll be your derivative
you try putting in x equals zero and
you'll just say forget it you're ending
up
with division by zero so the derivative
doesn't exist
what that means is the graph itself
doesn't exist okay
now there is another thing that it could
mean but i'm going to leave that off for
now because we've talked through a lot
of
theory at the moment i just want you to
leave a box here
and i will let that simmer in your brain
for a little bit to see if you can work
out
what else could it possibly mean apart
from the function doesn't exist okay